Чернігів — це історичне місто,
і його варто таким берегти.
Справжній Чернігів — це не лише
старовинні храми, печери.
Це так само і ця дерев'яна архітектура,
яка створює затишок
і приємну атмосферу нашого міста.
Багатство цієї архітектури
представлене на теренах України
саме в межах північної частини Чернігівщини
і північної частини Сумщини.
Таким чином, це така собі
регіональна родзинка,
яку ми маємо берегти,
якою ми маємо пишатися,
яка певною мірою формує те,
ким ми є,
оскільки наше середовище
дуже сильно визначає те,
якими ми стаємо людьми.
Мене завжди цікавили
і приваблювали ці будинки,
я вважав їх частиною свого середовища,
свого рідного Чернігова,
і, звичайно, підростаючи,
я бачив, що вони зникають.
Коли я трохи підріс,
я зрозумів,
що можу вплинути на цю ситуацію,
спробувати повернути
людям віру в дерево.
І показати, що дерев'яні будинки —
це, насправді, частина нас, чернігівців,
це частина нашої регіональної
культурної спадщини.
Була така ідея — піти і просто
почати говорити з власниками,
пропонувати їм допомогу.
Обрали красивий старовинний будинок
на одній з центральних вулиць Чернігова,
і нам там відмовили.
Сівши в машину після відмови,
ми просто поїхали на сусідню вулицю
і запропонували кільком іншим сім'ям
відновити фасад їхнього будинку.
Так у нашому розпорядженні
опинився будинок на Зеленій, 15,
який став першим відновленим об'єктом
проєкту «Дерев'яне мереживо
Чернігова» в місті Чернігові.
З оригінального оздоблення
цього будинку,
скажімо, з оцих-от елементів на карнизі,
збереглася десь половина,
а половина була поламана.
Ми зробили заміри,
купили матеріали,
і Чернігівський політех
вирізав нам 33 такі штуки.
Їх тут всього близько 60.
І так само ці пілястри, які ви
бачите зараз, вже повністю нові.
Збереглися тільки оті,
і то не в повному вигляді.
Ми зробили з них копію обрамлення
цих пілястр, так звані картуші.
Будинок, однозначно, став
найкрасивішим на вулиці.
Оскільки ми стартували як онлайн-музей,
то варто почати, мабуть, з цього.
Як онлайн-музей ми
запустили сайт шістьма мовами,
де є можливість прогулятися
п'ятьма маршрутами.
В Чернігові у фотогалереї
представлено близько 200 будинків,
і ще близько сотні представлені з області.
І сьогодні онлайн-музей
представлений будинками,
мабуть, десь з 13-14 населених пунктів.
Чернігівців варто знайомити
зі своїм рідним містом,
і реакція цих людей
дуже наочно показує,
чим ці будинки є для міста.
Ми з вами зараз
рухаємося по місцевості,
де дивитися взагалі немає на що,
але іноді буває таке,
що ви просто йдете
і виходите до будинку
з шикарним дерев'яним різьбленням
і з досить своєрідною історією.
Перед вами — цікавий будинок,
оскільки він єдиний,
який зберігся з усієї вулиці.
До 1970-х років існувала
суцільна дерев'яна забудова,
яку потім знесли і побудували
оце все навколо.
Якимось дивом зберігся цей будинок,
один в своєму роді,
а вся вулиця була знищена.
У чернігівській дерев'яній архітектурі
присутня така цікава річ,
як музичні інструменти.
Дуже часто у різьбленні зображають
ті чи інші інструменти, переважно струнні.
І друга річ, на яку варто звернути увагу,
бо більшість людей цьому дивуються,
але якимось чином у Чернігів
перекочував символ пальми
як оберіг, як символ добробуту.
Це один з будинків,
де такий символ можна побачити.
Ще таких будинків
у Чернігові, мабуть, п'ять.
Кінцева мета — це зберегти їх фізично,
але їх не можна зберегти фізично,
не переконавши людей у тому,
що дерево і оригінальний вигляд
цих будинків має значення.
А це можна зробити винятково шляхом
популяризації цієї архітектури.
Зараз ми швиденько пройдемося вулицею —
тут є красиві дерев'яні будинки,
зокрема один, який я дуже
хотів би відреставрувати.
Як на мене, це один з найкращих
будинків не лише цієї вулиці, а й міста.
Отакого формату сандриків,
тобто верхньої частини вікна,
у Чернігові практично немає.
До речі, Сергію,
таке до тебе запитання.
Дивись, а в Гомелі які віконниці?
Вони такі, як тут, односкладні,
чи вони бувають складні?
[білоруською]
Вкрай у рідких випадках вони складні.
[білоруською] Наприклад, квадратне вікно —
вони можуть бути асиметричними:
[білоруською] у чотири чи в три рази
складаються, а у них це...
І в нас так само.
У нас у Чернігові двоскладних
я не скажу скільки,
але дуже мало, менше,
ніж пальців на двох руках.
[білоруською] А вулиця Дзержинського —
це, я сподіваюсь, стара назва?
Так, це стара табличка,
це вже давно не Дзержинського,
а Любомира Боднарука — композитора.
Більшість з цих будинків не мають
жодного охоронного статусу.
Це просто приватні будинки,
причому часто розділені на кілька сімей.
Коли ми починали всю цю діяльність,
ми розуміли, що наша цільова
аудиторія — це не так міська влада,
як саме приватні власники
цих будинків.
І на прикладі тих об'єктів,
які ми вже відреставрували
або реставруємо прямо зараз,
ми можемо показати,
що це все не так складно й зробити.
Це не складно,
не дорого,
є люди, які готові
допомогти з цим.
Люди, які роблять це винятково
на волонтерських засадах,
які роблять це з любов'ю до міста.
Знаєте, що я найбільше люблю?
А де наш, до речі,
білоруський друг дівся?
Ага, он він підходить.
Одна з речей, які я найбільше люблю,
коли воджу такого роду екскурсії,
(ходімо)
це вдаватися
до інструменту забазарювання.
Ти йдеш собі, умовно кажучи,
ні про що розмовляєш.
А потім — бац!
І через якісь хащі виходиш до одного
з найкрутіших будинків у місті.
І, власне, з мережива з цього вікна
взятий логотип
«Дерев'яного мережива Чернігова».
Якось воно мені дуже подобається,
і сам будинок по собі досить специфічний.
Якщо мереживо на карнизі
розповсюджене в Чернігові,
то ось ці пілястри — унікальні,
різьблення над вікном — унікальне.
І сам будинок за рахунок своєї барвистості
створює таку приємну, позитивну,
грайливу атмосферу.
І мені б хотілося,
щоб значно більше будинків у Чернігові
мали такий зовнішній вигляд
і збереглися в такому стані.
Людей в команді не так і багато,
але дуже добре, що у проєкту є велика
база поціновувачів мережива,
і є люди, які завжди радо
приєднуються на якісь толоки
і підтримують якісь окремі ініціативи.
У команді є двоє програмістів,
один історик, професійна журналістка,
ну і я там теж збоку.
І, таким чином, ми можемо покривати основні
напрямки діяльності проєкту на сьогодні.
Є, звісно, дуже багато людей,
які просто нас підтримують на тому
чи іншому етапі з тими чи іншими ідеями.
Наприклад, коли ми
реставруємо якісь будинки,
до нас приєднуються
професійні будівельники,
нам допомагають люди з якихось
інших сфер, у яких є певне обладнання.
Наприклад, Чернігівський політех, який допомагає
нам вирізати мереживо на станку.
Чернігівське різьблення досить просте.
Воно, звичайно, буває
дуже-дуже красиве,
але в плані свого виконання
це, все-таки, пропильне різьблення,
коли береться дошка,
і в ній випилюється певний візерунок.
На противагу, скажімо,
об'ємному різьбленню,
коли стамесками вирізають
якісь красиві об'ємні форми.
Це значно багатше різьблення,
і воно складніше для виконання.
У Чернігові представлене переважно
пропильне різьблення,
у Чернігові мереживо представлене
переважно в декорі вікон.
Причому, лише згори.
Дуже мало в Чернігові прикрашаються
будинки під вікнами.
Таких реально одиниці.
У Чернігові дуже багато рослинних
орнаментів і солярних символів.
Це дуже часто якісь листочки, гілочки.
І дуже багато солярних символів,
тобто того, що відображає зірки або сонце.
Такого вистачає.
Усі люди низького зросту
можуть підходити до мене,
тому що дивитися ми будемо не
з цього боку паркану, а бажано з цього.
Так, якщо тут раптом буде собака,
не бійтеся, заходьте.
Ми з вами перебуваємо
біля так званого будинку Дроздова.
Це один з найкращих будинків міста
і будинків, чия історія заворожує,
тому що ця земля колись належала
Михайлу Коцюбинському,
який пізніше продав її своєму
знайомому Йосифу Дроздову,
який, власне, і збудував
цей будинок для себе.
У 2000-х роках цей будинок вибила для себе
громадська організація «Інтеграція».
Це організація, яка об'єднує
людей на інвалідних візках,
і, якщо не помиляюсь,
з листопада 2013 року
вони почали реставрувати цей будинок.
На сьогодні ми
реставруємо третій будинок.
Усі будинки — сторічної давнини,
так би мовити, їм всім 120+ років.
Якраз останній,
з яким ми сьогодні працюємо,
це будинок, до того ж, внесений
в реєстр пам'яток історії.
Будувався будинок 1890 року.
Будинок в непоганому стані.
Він може бути відновлений.
І в ньому можуть жити далі.
Рідко коли люди відновлюють
старі будинки за свій кошт.
А люди, ось це молоде покоління, вирішило:
«Давайте, будемо робити!».
Стартом проєкту на Успенській
було розуміння того,
що доведеться міняти досить
багато дерев'яних деталей.
А от що робити з віконницями?
Тому що це вже трошки інша парафія.
Я запостив черговий
допис у фейсбуку з тим,
що нам потрібні будуть
архітектор і столяр.
І одна з подруг нашого проєкту запропонувала
кількох своїх знайомих столярів.
І Микола, по суті, першим
відповів на моє повідомлення,
сказав, що йому це цікаво.
Якщо це якась музейна реставрація,
то там використовують,
наприклад, клей того часу,
і навіть деревину
намагаються того часу знайти,
а тут ми зробимо так,
що технологію збережено.
Ми робимо за тією ж технологією.
Плюс візьмемо сучасні технології
і поєднаємо їх зі старовинними.
І це буде красивий будиночок вже.
А це буде зроблено так, як і в ті часи,
тобто ті дядьки, які робили
ці віконниці старенькі,
так само, як я, стояли, теж такі
красиві, бородаті, і теж так раз-раз!
Тим, хто живе в Чернігові, всім шкода,
що архітектура псується в місті,
що якісь панельки, коробки [будуються],
що Чернігів має якісь цікаві речі,
але ми всі скаржимось,
але нічого не робимо.
А Стас нічого не каже —
він просто робить.
Вже один будинок я бачив, який вони
відреставрували, мабуть, і не один.
І навіть якщо вся ця вулиця буде
з білої цегли і бетонних парканів,
цей будинок залишиться,
і люди будуть приходити,
фотографуватися, селфаки робити.
Попри всі наші негаразди,
мені хочеться жити тут.
Я мав не одну можливість
«звалити» з України.
Я завжди це пояснюю
таким банальним жартом:
якщо в інших розвинених країнах
уже все готове, там жити нецікаво.
Ви приїжджаєте туди —
і у вас вже є інфраструктура,
хтось вже зберігає архітектуру,
а в Україні — просто непахане
поле того, що можна робити.
В Україні жити цікаво,
тому що тут, куди не ткнися, —
всюди проблеми,
а це означає, що кожен
може знайти собі якусь нішу,
яку можна розвивати,
покращувати, рухати вперед,
і це, насправді, наповнює наше життя.
Мій Чернігів — це місто тихе, затишне,
зелене, доброзичливе, розвинене,
місто людей, які поважають одне одного
і поважають працю одне одного,
вміють критично мислити,
люблять одне одного,
люблять своє місто
і дбають усестронньо
про його збереження і розвиток.